bonjour je m'appelle j'y vais j'ai 30
ans j'ai deux passions la danse et
l'événementiel c'est pour cette raison
que j'ai décidé d'en terminer ma
carrière professionnelle dans
l'événementiel je dois définit comme une
personne à l'écouté créatif et inique
j'ai un parcours en trois étapes un
baccalauréat en gestion touristique
effectué en belgique un diplôme d'état
en tant que professeur de danse et le
formation diplômante accueil réception
c'est grâce à ces trois compétences que
j'ai pu effectuer des stages à l'office
de tourisme de saint paul où j'ai pu
proposer un projet innovant et ludique
ensuite géré également organisé le
premier salon du sport qu'est le santé à
saint pierre mon projet au jour
d'aujourd'hui d'intégrer une entreprise
dynamique et 100 % les frais de son
client si ma candidature au montpied
n'hésitez pas à me contacter